comment la procureure générale figure de
proue des enquêtes sur les crimes de
guerre présumés commis par les russes et
le chef des services de sécurité ont-ils
pu être sanctionnée de cette manière par
le président ukrainien que s'est il
passé alors ça a été annoncé hier
confirmé aujourd'hui avec un ou deux
modes si une suspension de postes est
pas une démission de leurs fonctions en
fait officiellement vous l'avez dit ce
qui leur est reproché c'est de ne pas
avoir finalement fait le ménage si vous
passez l'expression dans leur
administration d'avoir laissé travailler
des employés de l'administration
travaillé dans les zones occupées par
les russes d'avoir transmis certaines
informations sensibles aux services de
sécurité russes et finalement de les
laisser d'avoir laissé faire de la
trahison de la collaboration et à
présent il y a six cent cinquante et une
procédure pénale qui ont été enregistrés
a dit le président ukrainien donc ce
qu'il leur est reproché c'est pas la
tradition pour eux-mêmes mais bien de
leurs employés et pour le moment une
enquête est en cours d'après le
correspondant de rfi dans la région
stefano stewards c'est le parlement
ukrainien qui in fine est pourrait
décider du sort de ces deux proches en
fait du président vs alors ça c'est la
version officielle hier génique que dit
on dans la presse ukrainienne alors là
président l'apprécient chrétienne dit
que à la fois irina benedicto vaille 25
nov était très était sur la sellette
depuis un certain nombre d'années de
deux mois pardon c'est pourtant deux
très très proche du président ukrainien
notamment ils vendent bacanov qui était
un ami d'enfance qui a accompagné chaque
étape de sa carrière de la carrière du
président d'edf qui dans sa société de
production audiovisuelle aussi son
ascension au pouvoir et et jusqu'au
poste de président c'est hélène ski qui
l'a nommé d'ailleurs à la tête du
service de sécurité mais peut-être que
finalement ce poste était trop complexe
trop subtil pour lui lui qui n'avait
absolument aucune expérience dans ce
domaine du renseignement et qui avait
donc sous lui trente mille employés dont
un certain nombre effectivement été des
agents doubles et il n'a pas réussi à
contrôler tout ça donc finalement zen ce
qui sous un peu forcé de peut-être lâché
quelqu'un qui est très très proche pour
justement rétablir rétablir un peu
d'ordre quant à la procureure ce qui lui
est reproché c'est d'être un peu trop
zélé dans les dents les procès à
l'encontre des prisonniers russes vous
savez que les prisonniers russes vont
être à l'avenir le sont déjà mais en
goutte de plus en plus une monnaie
d'échangé aussi contre des prisonniers
ukrainien et qu'elle était peut-être un
peu trop intransigeante pour réussir à
entrer dans des négociations
merci virginie